i know and wasn't supposed to cry this
evening andrew garfield is feeling all
the feels the actor tearfully takes the
stage at the 2022 costume designers
guild awards as he accepts the spotlight
award presented by his tic tick boom
co-star judith light please welcome the
remarkable the extraordinary the
infinitely talented and wildly generous
andrew garfield
[Music]
i know i wasn't supposed to cry this
evening um and and judith just made me
do that when andrew takes the podium he
gets real about his emotions i'm just so
surprisingly overwhelmed and touched
to be in this room with
my community and
so many collaborators that i love and i
value and why the honor from the costume
designers means so much you are my
favorite people to collaborate with you
are the truly the best i feel like the
luckiest
most fortunate actor alive you've given
me a big task to not get big headed
after tonight and i promise you i'll do
my best to pop pop the bubble when i get
home but before andrew accepted his
award he shared even more praise on the
red carpet it's the costume designer
that
solidifies and affirms and redirects and
and more often than not offers something
that
is something that i would never have
previously imagined or thought of and
then enhances
my experience of playing the part the
tearful moment comes four months after
the actor got choked up during a visit
to the late show with stephen colbert
while discussing the loss of his mother
i love talking about it by the way so if
i cry it's only like
it's only a beautiful thing for me i got
to sing jonathan larson's unfinished
song
while simultaneously
singing
for my mother
and her unfinished song i'm indebted to
any everyone who's brought me to this
place so that i can
i can honor
the most beautiful person that i've ever
experienced in my life through my art
and use it as a way to heal use it as a
way to sew up the wounds andrew's mom
lynn who died in 2019 after battling
pancreatic cancer played a huge part in
his stunning portrayal of playwright
jonathan larson in tiktik boom
there's not enough time
i went to three friends funerals last
year
and nobody is doing enough
i'm not doing enough
this film
she's in every frame for me as there is
of course
an endless sorrow in having to say
goodbye to my mother in in incarnate
form but i know she's here i know she's
here it's been a milestone time for the
actor who nabbed his first golden globe
win in january next up the oscars later
this month maybe i'm just wasting my
time do you know how many jonathan
larsons there are
one i'm just grateful to be here and
that's the truth and i love this film i
love this character i love this company
of actors and tonight's about community
tonight's about you know us loving each
other in this community that was android
the sag awards last month where he was
also a nominee and where he made his red
carpet debut with a very special lady
girlfriend alyssa miller a source tells
et that the two are doing really well
and bring out each other's good sides
they're comfortable with each other and
andrew is in a great place and very
happy i'm very lucky i'm lucky that i
get to tell stories i'm lucky that i get
to act i wanted to do this since i was a
kid so to be stood here talking to you
guys is an honor
[Music]
you